[Music]
thank you you guys excited for that mrs.
Doubtfire sequel yeah I was watching the
original in the other day and I remember
at the end of the movie when the mask
comes off Sally Field she keeps going
Daniel it was you the whole time
the whole time because really wouldn't
it be so much worse if it wasn't him the
whole time went there was already a mrs.
Doubtfire
now she's chained to his radiator
somewhere it was like no not the whole
time three weeks ago I followed mrs.
Doubtfire home and I knocked her out
with chloroform now I'm wearing her skin
I just want my kids back
[Music]
it's weird I always pick up on stuff
like that in like movies and music like
I noticed the other day there's a lot of
songs out there about like catching
somebody who cheated on you but you
don't hear any songs about like thinking
somebody cheated on you and then
confronting them and then you're wrong
and now you just stand there like an
idiot
and listen to her explanation of where
she was and it makes sense I give her
that Whitney Houston song she's like
Friday night you and your boys went out
to eat but only two of you had dinner
I found your credit card receipt what if
the guy in that song is like that's
because we split the bill three ways and
then Tommy gave me cash and then I used
my
for the two of us you psychopath what
did you what did you dig through my
trash again I thought that was gonna
stop
she's like whoops I'm sorry I'm just go
to bed now I live in New York City right
now and I was on the street the other
day I saw a family the parents were
white and the kids were Asian they were
adopted obviously but uh okay that's the
setup but whenever you see that doesn't
it feel like those parents are like
showing off a little bit like when they
selected the baby they were like white
one no one's gonna know that we're
heroes
[Laughter]
thank you I'm from Jersey originally
very nice yeah I'm from like a very
Italian part of Jersey and one thing I
remember about growing up there is like
how heartbreaking it would be when your
cue teacher would get married
and her cute name would change to
something gross like you come back from
summer vacation you're like oh hey miss
loomio how was your summer she's like
actually like I got married I'm no
longer Miss loomio now I miss his
goo-goo-goo gots I'm like oh good to
know
you've been soiled by a fat contractor I
was taking some personal about me I have
a brother who's actually mentally
challenged he has a severe autism and I
have another brother who's not autistic
though and a friend of mine met that
brother recently I have an autistic
brother because that's me goes yeah Mike
I just met your brother he's like barely
autistic
I know I think that's a funny thing to
learn about yourself you're not autistic
but people think you are but you need to
stop blinking so much stop wearing that
propeller hat everywhere my my autistic
brother he does Special Olympics like
every year and this year he got
disqualified from a race like that's a
thing they do the Special Olympics
athletes apparently somebody had to blow
a whistle in his face and be like get
out of here you're done and here's why
he got disqualified he was in a walking
race a speed walking race and he ran and
he was like reprimanded for that but
yeah does that make any sense to you
guys why did they do that
he didn't ruin Christmas or squeeze a
puppy too hard he figured out how to win
a race
[Applause]